it's not is not perfect but I wanted to
I wanted to start it on time let's get
this wall right home on the brick wall
I want this brick wall is ruining
everything I've ever believed in I
should have had this loaded up let's see
what we gonna do for the the backdrop
there we go oh there we go there we are
right all right all right let's go now
I'm able to kind of really capture what
my real-time mental state is about the
brick wall
pammi nice with our third I'm in here
producing the brick wall can stay for a
little bit but tomorrow yeah every
quarter I wanted to talk about Miami
nice I thought it'd be fun to just go
through the specials and and really
watched him because I haven't watched
them in a while I've seen bits but I
have a set and just really watch the
full' because it's uh stuff to do there
we go
here's animal furnace animal furnace we
film in 2011 at the Gramercy in New York
it premiered in May 2012 my first
special they found a few people specials
that week at the at the Gramercy was
kind of a did a block shoot I think
Peter home shot that week time Barry a
few other folks shot in the same venue
and in a very budget-conscious move by
Comedy Central
let's get up let's get the venue for a
week shoot a bunch of people that's how
you do it
all right let's get into it
Sonne trim ate this beat we did a this
extra shoot wasn't a very inspired it's
like look at my hands like hands that
watch how's a decent little watts
Glatt look the glasses what if what are
we trying to get across here okay okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
should have leaned into that more I was
crazy security really pressed me
security press the hell out of me and my
own and my own comedy special and yeah I
think he had on a laminate with my face
on into something for my name on it
that's happened that that happened
either even at big venues and where who
who are you what are you what are you
doing here y'all it's just you just
trying to it's trying to come to work to
the stage
also giving out video I'm having at the
bleep I didn't remember they bleep that
I changed their name I said like I said
I said a fake name
that's a I'm just kind of ruining that
were that show was uh house for Sunday
School sessions actually we used to do
that show you know what this brick wall
oh whoa I removed it hold oh there we go
let's see which one looks better like
that nope let's see let's see
hey hey vote in the chat which look
Barrett which one you want to say you
want to see that you want to do it like
this how you want to see in the chat
like subscribe share let me know how you
feel about brick walls do you like it
what do you think let me know in the
chat everybody you know what it is let
me know in the chat let me know in the
chat like subscribe microphone
as he shot his own microphone a lot of
people asked me what what band this is
and the band is this band model tonics
Oh occasionally they would take the
crowd outside they will just lead the
crowd outside at the show
Oh let's see how they are at a festival
hi guys not in the band
[Music]
hold up hold up hold up listen you are
somebody say there's the check
sorry about that now we're gonna get
back into some had a mold furnace okay
kind of a furnace a stranger on the
internet named the special for me I
asked some folks for names and and he
reply animal furnace and I said perfect
yeah I'll have it be that for the rest
of my life and nope no regrets at all
I'm gonna go to my back in just you two
but maybe we just do a couple bits all
right okay let's see let's sleep let's
leave was going on let's go wait let's
go away strip clubs I thought it I go to
a black strip club white strip clubs a
bar and they're good bars or naked
chicks that's cold
the bar bad strip club they danced all
the songs on white strip clubs don't see
dance - barely mastered it dope so sick
stands for shoes danced to Madonna still
I stand on this a hundred percent I
stand on this bit I yeah they just I
don't know what it is what is just fix
them fix it better songs watch it dance
to the songs that rappers made
specifically for the strip club money
that I made selling crack no
it's good it's good for this environment
I went to a concert I saw this fruit
beautiful form with the clothes in the
hook to their clothes a song with school
what does it seem like they get more
reasonable as they go along
I heal people that's murder that's right
go ahead do you think school truancy
what are you standing on man that's a
weak present miss bass before don't get
more more reason when I rap
[Applause]
why don't we started a menu ten instead
of the channel I was watching already
I've already seen limitless souls you
trying to get me to download the new
birds I got a new birds a couple of days
ago I was his friend
the baby's news I saw our future
what was the venue they performed it was
a show in New York was it Santos party
house a something and they they I was I
think I was a 28 at the Sun at the time
but they Tyler something like oh you old
[ __ ] you owe [ __ ] not having
a good time it was and I felt attack I'm
mi Oh I mean I'm 28 do gray shells make
a good time let's sleep let's get him to
the let's get into the next one
Oh Jake jaywalking that one too
jaywalking that's a five point two [ __ ]
you know what so you saw how if I want
to get to [ __ ]
see but take it in my when we did deals
with specials we didn't know that y'all
be putting them breaking them up putting
them on YouTube ya know whatever do I
couldn't believe it
I've seen walked so many times in my
life is such an easy thing to time out
is there car coming nah let me get
across there I've done it thousands of
times but this time it was me and this
old lady we walk so hold on let's back
up a little bit
look at that elbows pretty a sheet that
day for some reason and I didn't notice
it until I don't know if I noticed it
afterwards or in the editing session I
was telling the editor on a lot of shots
so just kind of keep up keep close so my
ashy elbow wouldn't be exposed which is
kind of a running theme for my specials
but that one was a super obvious that
was just for me but for comedy kamisato
which will be are we talking about that
one Friday at 3 o'clock Pacific 6:00
Eastern there's a stray hair on my head
and that straight hair took on a life of
his own on the internet people made a
fake Twitter account for it and so a lot
of the shots I will try to avoid the
ashy elbow as also I think there's some
show one show too I wonder if this is
all from one show off is cut around but
they were versions of jaywalking bit at
first they were never fuel more by anger
and energy than the structuring and joke
writing I think there was some early
version this bit was 20 minutes long at
certain points just because it was a
really infuriating situation I never
paid that ticket I could have just just
gave them my info right away but that's
not that's not how I'm wired
although they threatened to follow me to
the hotel I don't know is this Billy
might just make it
this is great lady we was jaywalking
together who wants to gather like that
but if we were so what my your business
I just met y'all samhitas old lady we
get across the street that a Montreal
cop approaches us speaking in French ah
goddamn it I lengthen to that one aisle
it I grabbed all of that and did not let
that [ __ ] go I said hey man I don't talk
like that that's not how I talk can you
talk to me how I talk it probably wasn't
the best way to start off by interaction
by Mike and his native language but who
cares
I take risk like he said you would say
walking and I said sorry about that and
I tried to keep going about my day cuz I
thought that's how jaywalking was
handled as a crime you would say walking
my bad we're done here right that's it I
acknowledge that I'd say well I
apologize that but I acted a walk about
how my jaywalking make you feel I'm
trying to say walk in the future while
you're watching for us and we'll do it
the rest of my life is the best way to
go about being a pedestrian
and he says no I have to give you a
ticket give me your ID I said you
understand all he gets people might be
for real stuff this is not real this is
a fantasy crime that you're forced to
cover up the fact that the city is
having financial problems right now the
city is broke and it puts you out here
with a quota that's fine I will donate
60 of the colorful as dollars to your
broke-ass City and that's the store like
that no paperwork and it's good I wish
they for speeding tickets just run my
car here don't try to give me a court
date in the middle of Wisconsin or some
[ __ ] don't make me have to go to court
in Appleton Wisconsin or just swipe the
card just if that's what it is let's
just give the cops [ __ ] square reader
for the petty stuff instead of trying to
you know do all the paperwork and
everything this is this is do it like
the tax collection cops show up now we
have three Montreal police officers
working as high-profile jaywalking case
that was so bonkers that they had backup
for jaywalking
I didn't even jump are you trying to run
away they had three three people I don't
listen to my story bits like that at all
really just hearing it again I'm
reliving the joke for the first time in
years and and now I want to go square up
a little bit but I can't because America
as I banned from leaving the country
mostly right now so I can't even go have
revenge
Hey three cops to me and jaywalker fair
enough I decided during a time that I
was gonna talk trash to the cops and
closest to me because I don't like him
or what he represents us I just want to
mess with him inside say hey man how
much money do you make it was a douchey
thing to do three cops jaywalking ticket
this is really this is super obnoxious
cuz I wasn't even how was it you make it
I was making crazy it was I was tripping
over kid I only have two legs that's a
cop and a half per leg that's a waste of
city fun that's why the city in krump
now and he told me how much he made I
don't know why he told me he didn't have
to tell me if you say how much do you
make and I told him they got upset what
do you say on drugs he really said that
[ __ ] like some of the parts are
exaggerated that's the thing with
storytelling some parts blah blah French
that's obviously fake right but him
saying him asking me if I sold drugs was
that was real it's kind of racist what
you say old cars asking me if I sell
cars was also real now I'm in this
bonkers just fantasy Lane what the hell
type of conversation I wonder if they
remember if you had Montreal let us know
in the chat if you're in Montreal and
you're that cop let us know in the chat
like subscribe share one love playing
one ocean first two guesses eight is
dude is doing something illegal people
love my super rules problem he's a
charismatic guy stare the hell out of a
car I was the only two times an
oversized police officer I'm a dumb guy
our world views live knows when I say
hey man your colleague he's 50 years old
and he's right jaywalking tickets for
living he considered a failure as a
police officer let's say like some stuff
that you should be doing he was a young
guy he was upset about that he was being
an ass that's amaz it cost to be an ass
the Montreal police in case you cries
out for your next vacation hours hours
speeding so much is wow so that's why I
don't watch a lot of stuff even those
you know tag good show they did well
just now with some time watch oh I was
speeding through and some thoughts might
not have you know they didn't get hit as
much because I kind of death at that
speed threw him a little bit I never
paid that ticket and it's never been an
issue but Canada will they well I want
them getting into Canada if you have any
type of history can be a struggle so now
with kovat going to Canada what we're
going to do how we all gonna get to ovo
fest back to the biz but don't worry
don't worry about me I'm that parent
either of Little Miss Canada it doesn't
count to me it's now real
I was at the airport it was this kid
four or five years old
walking with his mommy fixed his fingers
and a fake gun and then took the shot at
me now I'm looking at the wall to see if
there's something on the wall that could
have been shooting there cuz I'm in
denial I look back at him he looks near
my eyes takes two more shot I'm hit
three times that was an act of
aggression I have to defend myself I'm a
man pointing a point-blank bang shoot
this kid my other efforts I don't like
them at all they seem so dedicated to
keep them bottled so some people that
have flown now I haven't flown since
late February early March now where
kovat is a bigger obstacle have they
loosened their their policy on bringing
your own bottled water yet are they
still holding strong on bottled water
let me know in a share like subscribe
share one look wat out of the sky that's
the main thing it's probably easy to get
cocaine on the plane than a bottle of
water probably all the way we couldn't
get it what is this out of water
who gate somebody gave me that Ted who
gave me that Sam that's not the the
powdered water I'm I had to ask her but
Morgan Murphy mighta giving me that tag
after seeing the show and she wrote a
couple lines well here's a couple bits
that some people have helped punch up a
little bit but I'm pretty certain organ
Murphy wrote the powdered water tag was
cocaine go right ahead
enjoy your flight because of terrorists
try to live with bonding and nobody can
bring good was on a plane one person
messed up for everybody but I feel like
that's being reactive instead of
proactive because terrorists are trying
new stuff so next time is gonna be some
type of Snickers bar after that half is
you can't bring full-size Snickers on
the plant anymore
gonna bring minutes of Snickers one
person mess it up for everybody security
situation T is able to cause heavy
traffic the other stuff I kind of uh
noticing I'm what Oh what were you doing
here but for some reason when I'm
watching the TSA material I'm just uh yo
this dude
preacher he is preaching the other stuff
I'm nitpicking like this dude is he
preach preach what not is not by water
what if I set the water to show you that
it's not water
that's why why do you been silly right
now man
no such thing as Bob water super bummer
hey bonbon typical Bob let's make that a
hook somebody loop that up put it on
some scuba bomb why we drop it on Friday
looks great about the only scrutiny they
rub the cloth on my hands didn't even
attested they came back say are you good
okay cool good thing I didn't have Bob
juice on my hands who's that got the
bomb juice s what if I did have Bob
juice on my hands what if one of my
friends before you go to the airport
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's pretty cool thanks man real cool
and I get to the airport I test my hands
they say you have bomb juice in your
hands is there anything you'd like to
tell us yeah one of my friends he got a
bunch of bombs and he said you want to
hold a bomb real quick before you go to
the airport I never held a bomb before
so I thought it'd be something cool to
do I made sure not to bring the bomb
with me because I know y'all hate that
so I want to just hold a bomb real
because I think you need to chill out
and stop being jealous because I got all
types of grants some of my friends own
bombs
let me hold up you open up your social
circle and meet some new people
I shouldn't I I just thought of the tank
I just thought of a tag eight years
later you need to open up your social
circle meet some people
come through we plan to K we shooting
dice there's an air hockey tournament on
Thursday let's dump that in let's
actually do a different version and then
I'll get on the green screen shoot it
with the same backdrop cut my hair a
little bit get the glasses ask my elbow
a little bit and then throw that line in
there yet air hockey coming up BAM oh
let's knock that out get that shot
for business or pleasure I'm born in New
York talk about you in front of
strangers fog us both that does is
something that's really really annoying
about si si not being systemized or that
systemized that the process is not being
the same with everybody si si the
government agency but it seemed like a
lot of them have their own individual
processes and so when you run into
somebody with their own quirky way it
could throw you off they some people ask
you where you going some people don't
some people you know say what say your
name everybody need to do the same thing
isn't that open for interpretation have
some some some bang like some this is
what we do so then when I go there I
know sometimes been caught off guard
sometimes I said the wrong city just to
just oppress them where are you going
and they holding the boarding pass
Sacramento and then you just stare and
then they just hand me my boarding pass
them in their friend takes my lotion
look at that's all right that big shirt
on television we'll get into that maybe
Thursday we'll talk about this shirt and
and all of that I'm looking for
don't forget let's see this an example
of a banner just click on a banner to
show it on is great for sure appreciate
I want I wanna I wanna look at a one of
my favorite uh gibberish rap
performances and I was it was able to
share my music let's see their life is
gibberish rap was maybe Cleveland back
then I was spending more money on my
shelves and I should have been and I was
getting costumed characters and
ballerinas I think this one if a
Cleveland
Ramon Rivas was helping out we were able
to you know doing balloon animals up
here so this is at the 2012 I don't
think I even crap in my socks at all
much change scenes degrees put on
deodorant so sit hold spit
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Miami nights on Friday I'll be here
tomorrow at 6 o'clock Pacific 8:00
central 9:00 Eastern talked about life
from Chicago but as you see my veer off
who knows what's going to happen it
could end up we could end up anywhere I
have a ps4 just because some friends
suggested actually the director out of
special Chris mark so yeah don't say how
Chris mark stuff amazing director
director animal furs but yeah I got this
game on last of us last of us to and I
thank y'all for watching this was really
fun so to see this stuff and we do it
all week
mr. Lewman media